cool
good morning first talk of the day
and this is a title slide my company
would want me to use
um
this is the one that I would really want
to use
um I noticed when I Was preparing this
talk and talking to some people about it
that there is some kind of an age Gap
it's like people under 35 they don't
actively remember celebrity that watch
that match and people who are like my
age and older they do and so I figured
for the younger people in the room that
I explain a little bit like there's this
TV channel called Music Television now
it shows mostly reality shows
um and like dating dating programs but
it used to be about music because we did
not have the bandwidth to actually watch
videos in the 90s I mean YouTube didn't
exist
um downloading a song took an entire
evening over over dial up so if we
wanted to see the music clips we had to
watch television and we fell in love
with some artists at that time
and then MTV started thinking started to
think about what can we do differently
and that's when it all started going
downhill so celebrity that match is part
of that and we first got Biebs and butt
head you might remember those and and
there was also celebrity that match so
what was celebrity that match
um I was thinking about what am I gonna
name this talk I'm going to be talking
about actors versus actors I was
thinking celebrity that match is an
animated series with clay figures where
celebrities fight celebrities so you
often have actors fighting actors right
and it was really cool because they even
had these clay figure commentators I
think they were called Nick diamond and
and
um I have it written down somewhere
Johnny Gomez and there was also Mills
Lane who was the referee
um he had catchphrases like let's get it
on and whenever something sketchy
happened he's like I'll allow it right
and I remember like some of the episodes
very vividly like Toby Maguire against
Jake Gyllenhaal or Paris Hilton against
Nicole Richie actually MTV posted all of
these on YouTube so if if you're not
familiar go and watch it it's very gory
um I I left out all the gore but it gets
very bloody really quickly
all I'm trying to say is I watched MTV
when they were still cool I had to
invert this meme because mdv no longer
is cool
um but yeah it works
so having that out of the way
um let's get down to the order of the
day
um what am I going to talk about today
I'm first going to tell you why you
would want to use an extra framework
right try to keep that brief and I'll
give you a little bit of a history of
how we got to the point where we are
today
and and I'm going to show you some
shared Concepts between akan Orleans
stuff that is similar between the two
and then we will basically fight it out
and I'll show you some of the
differences between the two and and
hopefully by 10 10 o'clock we will come
to a conclusion and you can go and have
a coffee
so why would you want to use a
act one has changed in our industry
now first of all we are not writing
software at the same scale anymore as 20
years ago we've had an explosion of the
internet people are using smart devices
not just smartphones and watches but
like you probably have a bunch of
connected devices in your house as well
and a lot of the stuff that we do has to
be prepared for a much bigger scale
let's say that you write a back end for
an app if you're really planning to
scale that to millions of users you're
going to need a system that is able to
keep up with that right and we're no
longer running on Specialized Hardware
anymore and a lot of us when we do high
skill stuff we are deploying it to the
cloud and the cloud is basically a whole
bunch of commodity Hardware so we're
going to need to figure out a way to
scale with commodity Hardware to numbers
that we were previously not able to
imagine
and if we look at 50 years of evolution
in microprocessors and there's a couple
of trends that you could notice I mean
three to five gigahertz CPUs that has
been the norm for the last decade and a
half or so
um so that has stabilized completely and
what we also see is the single threat
performance it's tapering off it's still
increasing and there's a lot of Branch
prediction stuff that is making sure
that this is still advancing but it's
not advancing as much as the potential
number of users for our systems so we
need to look for a little bit of Hope
and the only hope that we have is this
when I started college
um I got like the best of the best it
was a Pentium tree a single core machine
right had 128 megabytes of RAM
and that was like a high-end spec PC at
that time now we all have probably eight
cores in in our pocket right and modern
laptops like like my new one it has 14
cores in
um in a simple laptop that I can carry
around
now to be able to use multiple cores
we're gonna need to use multiple threats
and if we need to use multiple threads
that's when stuff gets hard
because if we look at andal's law he's a
very smart gentleman who thought about
this way more than we did and he
describes how much you can theoretically
speed up a workload by throwing more
resources at it so if you add more CPUs
you're always going to be limited by the
amount of your code that can be executed
in parallel
if you can execute execute all of your
codes in parallel you can basically
scale to Infinity
but that is not the reality if we have
multiple threats we're always going to
be faced with state
and at some point more of our threats
are going to be accessing the same state
and then you get race conditions and
when you get race conditions you need to
introduce some kind of blocking right
you need to make sure that that
resources only be is only used by one
thread at a time
that opens you to the possibility of of
deadlocks which is not fun at all but
assuming that you can solve that
what you will have with shared state is
that you will have a bit of your code
that cannot run in parallel
all the access to this resource needs to
run in series and not in parallel which
is going to hurt our potential scaling
as per Emerald's law
so as and assuming you can do that
anybody here tried to manage their own
threat pool at some point in their
careers
was it fun
no I mean assuming that you you can get
the debt logs and the serializing out of
the way scheduling threats is hard I
mean if you have to do it by yourself I
prefer somebody smarter than me thinking
about that problem
and that is where all of these actor
Frameworks come in and we have a lot of
them now I mean a lot more than you
might realize there are actor focused
languages like erlang and elixir we have
Frameworks on the.net CLR you can do
actors in Dapper or Orleans protoactor
on the jvm there's a whole I mean the
list of of actor Frameworks on Wikipedia
is it's literally like two screens long
now what these Frameworks promise US is
you will write your code in a very
simple way because inside your actor
everything is going to be single
threaded so that's easy to reason about
but they promise you that if you have a
lot of actors you can get a very high
degree of parallelization which makes
your scale out a lot easier and almost
linear
and by keeping a lot of your state in
memory you can also go to very very low
latency situations and I'm sorry but
that is my company mandated
um lock screen
that apparently I cannot turn off
I have to use the right finger
um
and you can use these systems to be
extremely resilient as well I mean
there's resiliency built in so that you
can recover from exceptions
now we have a lot of them
um but I want to tell you a little bit
more about how we got to the point of
these two Frameworks coming to be right
now a lot of the initial research comes
from the 1970s and it was all
theoretical they did not have the
hardware to do a lot of the stuff that
they were thinking about
but Carl Hewitt he was basically
reasoning about how he could structure
code for artificial Intel intelligence
in
sort of neural network they didn't use
the term but it was something like that
and that's what was actors are all based
on this happened in 1973 this is not new
it has been around for a long time
and what he was reasoning about is how
can we use many independent processors
to process bigger workloads and those
models got refined by a whole bunch of
computer scientists and mathematicians
over the following decades until in the
80s Ericsson came up with a language
called erlang
um they in Erickson research like people
my age may remember it's the same time
we had Ericsson smartphones around
celebrity that much time right
um not smartphones dumb phones
um but they designed the language to be
extremely fault tolerant because when
they were designing these Telco systems
uptime was the way that they made money
every minute that you're down you cannot
charge customers for phone calls so they
were doing this research
um Joe Armstrong was one of the people
who worked on that a lot and they wanted
to be able to have multiple Telco
systems work together to be very very
resilient and that got applied in the
1990s to build the axd 301 it has been
their Flagship Telco system for more
than a decade it's a total of two
million lines of code about half of
which is erlang there's also some CNC
Plus in there
um they manage with these systems to get
nine nines of uptime
if you want to put that into perspective
that is 31 milliseconds of downtime per
year
right I cannot get that with anything I
ever wrote Never
but just to show that there is really a
lot of benefit in the resiliency of
these systems
and then it was a little bit quiet like
a lot of the mainstream software
development was happening in
object-oriented languages and and
procedural languages and these actual
models they live their own life on the
side
but then because of this explosion of of
the internet that I was telling you
about like the need picked up because we
need to be able to process stuff stuff
in parallel and that is what these
Frameworks are really good at
so in the Microsoft extreme Computing
group people were researching how they
could leverage their data centers now
known as Azure and their big data
centers that they have for office and
for exchange online and for Xbox live
and how they could leverage that and all
those commodity servers to to process
big workloads and when the time came to
actually release Halo 4 this is what
they used
and the approach that are lean Stakes to
an actor model is a bit opinionated and
they abstract some stuff around away
from it
but what you will see is that they take
some they take some steps to make it
easier for the developer but what they
did works really well especially if you
pair it with clouds more specifically
azure because they wanted to build
something that's extremely high
available and with almost linear scaling
and for Halo 4 that was really important
because they usually release games
around the holidays
um and then a lot of people are going to
be playing over the Christmas holiday
but your staff is going to be on holiday
as well so if you have problems I mean
that's not going to solve itself
um so they use this to be able to scale
it out almost linearly and Halo 4 was a
success so it all worked
around the same time
um two people started porting
um akka which is a framework built by
light bend on the jvm
and they started porting that to.net
because they had a need for an actor
system that works on.net and they learn
about each other's efforts
um Aaron and Roger they learn about each
other Aaron started a company called
pedabridge and
this has been growing ever since I mean
they increased performance every time
that they do a new release
um it's definitely production stable
um and it is very very performant
now they got permission from light Bend
to call it aka.net because the AKA name
comes from the jvm
um and they are some of the.net actor
systems there's there's others out there
um but they are two of the more popular
ones
now before we dive into the differences
I would like to say that
um a lot of the things that these
Frameworks do under the hood are
basically very very very similar there
is a lot more that is similar between
these two Frameworks than what actually
separates them right
now the whole idea is that an actor or a
grain they have different names for that
or leans calls it a grain and aka.net
calls as an actor the reason they call
it the grain is they speak about a
virtual actor model
or a virtual actor system
so they used some different names but
it's basically the same thing what you
will have is you will have an object
instance
um that has its own behavior
and
all of the state is going to be internal
to this object
so you're gonna have private fields
in your object that are actually
um portraying all the states that are
supposed to be in this actor and
everything that modifies that state or
all the stuff that needs to respond to
things that are going to happen to this
actor that is just code functions as
you're used to writing them
and the input is where it gets really
interesting the only way you can
actually talk to an actor is by sending
it a message
and those messages get processed one by
one in order
and this is important because because
they are executed one by one in order
you know that there is always only a
single thread that is going to be
running on your actor at any given time
and that makes the whole parallelizable
part really easy to reason about because
you don't have to worry about locking
when you're processing a message inside
an actor
this guaranteed single threat
dreadingness is what is going to enable
our almost linear scaling
now these messages
um what you will see is these are pretty
simple CLR objects and but they do get
passed around a network from time to
time so they get serialized and
deserialized
um as these systems operate
um AKA and Orleans have slightly
different approaches to that or Lanes
more often than AKA serializes MDC
realizes messages
um
but this this is something you have to
keep in mind so you might as well design
them for immutability it's going to make
your life so much easier
and then the big thing that ties all of
this together as I said I like smart
people thinking about this stuff for me
so that I don't have to
um and the thing that ties it all
together is the actor system or The Silo
right Orleans calls it a silo academic
calls it an actor system but they
basically do the same thing
is the orchestrator that ties it all
together
and the first thing that it does is it
manages the life cycles of your actors
you are never
instantiating an actor yourself you tell
the actor system to do it for you and
they spin it up and they can take it
down they can rehydrate it when you need
it again stuff like this and this is
managed by the silo or the actor system
also it takes care of all the messaging
and the addressing if you send a message
to a certain address the actor system
will make sure that it arrives in the
inbox of the particular actor and it
does then from those inboxes do all the
thread scheduling for us and the thread
scheduling is the stuff that I told you
earlier that I don't like doing it's the
hard part and they do that for us in
this system
there's also a way to set timers in both
actor systems it it works a little bit
differently in each but you can send
timed messages to actors and so if you
will have to build your own scheduler or
whatever like you could easily do it
with actors as well
and there's also a published subscribe
event bus in inside the actor system
now this is what ties it all together
but now we're talking about one node in
our cluster all these actor systems are
going to work together in a cluster
and this is where the scaling really
happens
um if we let them work together
we are able to Shard our actor across
all the nodes
and if we can Shard our actors actors
across a bigger cluster that allows us
to add more nodes and that way we can
enable that scaling
and when a note drops from the cluster
you can recreate the actors on another
node so that it can take over
um all of that can happen seamlessly and
so you're also adding resilience to your
cluster in this way
um
this near linear scale out it's actually
pretty amazing if you see the scaling
graphs
um of what they did with Halo like
adding 500 servers in classical
scenarios you're actually running into
limits with things like load balancers
and so on but with that they could
nearly linearly add nodes to their Halo
cluster and that works extremely well
so now we're going to do the thing that
separates them what is different in
these two Frameworks
and I want to say I'm opinionated
so I'm gonna let you guys be the judge
of this right what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna try and explain a difference
between the two Frameworks
and then you guys will be able to this
QR code will return on every voting
slide as well you can vote which
framework you liked better
right
um
so the first thing that we need to look
at is like what what kind of API do we
need to develop our actors when we're
doing our active development
um in our day-to-day job
and what we will see
um when we start in aka.net
creating an actor what we do is we
inherit from the receive actor or any of
the other actor based classes that there
are
and that's basically enables us to spin
this up as an actor in our actor system
and when we there is a possibility to
pass Constructor parameters through a
system called props we will see that in
a couple of uh slides and we can pass
parameter Constructors parameter
arguments
we can add Constructor parameters to
this to this actor the way that you're
used to
and if we want to handle specific
messages we need to have some kind of
Handler for it and as you can see if I
want to respond to the complete round
message I'm just going to call the
handle uh handle complete round method
below right which is
um easy to notice we can use
any.net class or struct as a message as
long as it's serializable and
deserializable you don't need to add any
attributes to it that takes care of all
of that by itself
so that works really well
um
it's um
if you write your code in that Handler
method the thing is this is a
synchronous by default
so what this does on the aqua.net actor
is it takes in the message it comes from
the inbox but it's not giving any
response the thread on the sender has
already exited
and if we want to send something back we
can use properties like sender.tel and
that goes to the inbox of the send
director right and that's how you can
actually respond to a message now
there's a lot more to it than that but I
think this is the basics like we inherit
from that receive actor we register some
handlers and we can respond to messages
send something back if we want
now in Orleans there it works a little
bit differently and we start by creating
an interface that has to
implement or inherit from one of the
base
interfaces that are in The Orleans
packages so this is one with um accuwit
as its key
and then what we will do is we will
basically make a synchronous methods as
members of our interface we can Define
our own in the way that we want to write
them
and I specifically named these
parameters content and not message
because Orleans will wrap the parameters
that you put in this function you could
have seven parameters and it will wrap
all of that into a message for you okay
so these are not the actual messages
they are the parameters to end and the
return types of your methods and and
Orleans will wrap that for you
now after you've made that interface
you're going to inherit from one of the
grain based glasses and Implement your
interface and that is basically all you
need to do I'm sure you've written a
sync code before if you if you've done
anything with.net and so you can do
whatever you want to do now Orleans uses
more specific serializers so if you want
to use anything that is not one of the
net based data types
you're going to need to add this
generate serializer attribute to it for
it to work with the Orleans message
serializers it's not a big deal but it's
something you have to think about
and your code goes there
but the cool thing here is
um in Orleans as opposed to akka the
caller will actually have a thread
waiting and it's going to wait for the
response to come back
so you can use a normal method return to
answer the caller of your message
so if you use an empty task that's going
to do nothing but you could send data
back in the way that you're used to in
other net programs right
so we have to figure out it's your time
to vote
what coding style that you like better
the academic one where the messages are
really explicit where you can register
handlers where the tell is one way and
the responses are on another thread and
another inbox or did you like The
Orleans one better that is a lot closer
to the normal C sharp that we're riding
in oo systems
um where we can actually just have
task-based methods to return okay you
like echo.net better good I'm going to
put it down as one point for AKA
um
cool second round in our fight
once we've coded our actors we're going
to need to spin them up inside a silo
inside an actor system and the way that
that works and I'm going to start with
Orleans now
um the way that that works from the
outside is we get something called a
grain Factory when you instantiate an
Orleans client you have an injectable
grade Factory that you can use in your
asp.net controllers or wherever you want
to use it and that grain Factory allows
you to call this getgrain method
and the Gap grain methods with the
interface of our actor that will
actually tell the actor system to tell
the cluster to spin up one of these
actors and with Orleans we have to give
it an ID
because the ID of any actor like
echo.net actors don't have to have an ID
you can do whatever you want
um but this needs it because that's
going to determine the sharding in the
cluster right and it's also going to
make sure that when the actor gets
recreated it fetches the right data
and what we're going to get back week
after that we get a grain back and we
can call the async methods on
on that grain that we get back but we
never hold the reference to the actual
grain
what you're getting back from this grain
Factory is a proxy that is allowed that
is able to talk to the actual grain
somewhere around the cluster right
that's the way that works and when we
hit that Sync here that's basically the
threat not pausing in the async on your
method on your actor no it's actually
your local threat pausing while the
network round trip to your
um to your grain is happening and you
getting a response back right so that's
why these methods need to be task based
so that this can all work and the way
that we want it to work
and the return types that we're actually
getting from those methods is actually
the stuff that we're gonna get back
um when we execute this on the client
side right very straightforward not hard
to do
that it looks a little bit differently
when we are creating
um
actors we're going to need to tell the
actor system
um how it needs to be instantiated which
Constructor parameters we need to pass
and we do it with something called props
and the best way to explain props is
saying it's a Constructor pointer
so it tells us which Constructor to use
with which parameters on a certain class
to spin up an actor
so we first create those props
um with the props that create and
Factory method and what we can then do
these this is just a params array of
objects so you can pass whatever
Constructor parameters you need
and then you're gonna tell the actor
system to create that actor for you and
same here we're not getting back a
reference to the actual actor we're
getting back an i actor ref
and I actorf is a really powerful thing
it's an object it's the same the same
way it works the same way as the one in
the grains the proxy and this is
serializer serializable and you can pass
it around your network and it'll keep
working which is extremely powerful in a
lot of things that you do
and now we are doing it asynchronously
um so we have a tell and tell is just
sending a message to the inbox of that
actor there is a synchronous method you
could also do the um
fire and forget thing with Orleans
actors and here we have something
similar as the Orleans way is doing an
ask
and basically all that does is it's
sending a message to the Inbox and
waiting for a particular message to come
back so the coding on the actor side
Remains the Same as you've seen in the
previous round but this is like the
synchronous way
now in the American Army they have asked
don't tell
when you're doing echo.net you should be
thinking about tell don't ask like this
is kind of like an empty pattern you
don't want to be using this with
echo.net unless in certain scenarios
you're talking to actors from the
outside and you're going to want to wait
for a response but inside your actor
system this is really like a pattern you
should steer away from
so that's how that works
um
so
how would you prefer to create your
actors we can have a factory with
interfaces and proxies and async methods
which is really easy to do and furry.net
like
and on aka.net you're going to need to
do props and you're going to have actor
refs and you can do tells and you can do
asks
interesting
it means that I
until now whichever I put first is the
one you preferred we have more rounds I
swap them around on purpose to not be
biased okay let's see what happens on
the next round we're going to start with
AKA again
um as I said actors need organizing and
they need sharding especially if you're
using a cluster and there are some
subtle differences between the two
Frameworks there
now if we look at echo.net
actors live in a tree in a hierarchy
right there's three that we get for free
whenever we spin up an actor's system
it's the root the user and the system
actor and everything that you create
like we saw in the previous round if you
do actorsystem.actor off what you're
creating is a top level actor
now these actors they can create
children right and so these parents they
kind of have children and your um
identifier in an actor system is defined
by your place in the tree
so the one at the bottom right is called
slash user slash A2 slash B3 right
and that address needs to be unique
um so you're gonna have to
um if you don't give them names I could
will take care of it for you but
sometimes you want to address your
actors by their address so you're gonna
have to make sure that then you generate
them in a unique way
now when
um
when we do these these top level actors
what you've seen in the previous round
is is we make props and then create the
actor true that if you create a child it
is very similar it's the code in the
bottom the only thing is different is
that it's different is instead of actor
system we're using context
and if you use context actor F of what
you're doing is creating a child actor
for your current actor
now when we start clustering these notes
together
each one of them has their own actors
and we can have an a um an A2 B3 in on
every node if we so wish because that
will not conflict because the full
address of an actor is defined by the
node and and they're placed in the
hierarchy
but if we want to start to implement
sharding we have full control we can
distribute our shards the way that we
want to there is an
aca.cluster.charting package that
provides an abstraction on top of
um these these clusters but basically
what you do when you implement an
academic cluster is you have a bunch of
actor systems that are able to talk to
each other
so as soon as you set up clustering all
you do is you create a
um a ring of
um nodes that are talking to each other
but where your actors go you can
basically have full control over them
there's a whole ways of doing it and if
you don't want to go for the sharding
package you could build something called
routers where you could use a hash that
is computed on a certain message to go
to a certain node and if you don't have
a mechanism that spins up your actor on
that note that is your sharding
mechanism so you can do a lot you can do
a lot of different things
also in an academic cluster every node
can have a certain role and depending on
what actors you're instantiating you can
choose to not use or use certain roles
in your cluster
so you have the full control over that
now in Orleans it works a little bit
differently
and they don't call it an actor system
they call it a silo and Grains live in a
silo and your identity
um for an Orleans grain is your type of
grain and then the identifier that
you've given right we saw the eye grain
with gooit key and if you have the same
if you have different Goods like that
needs to be unique in your entire
cluster
that's also going to determine which
node a certain grain goes onto
and there's no no
there's no hierarchy so it's basically
like a bunch of marbles in a bag you
have a silo and you can drop a lot of
cranes into that and the system will
distribute them for you
so in that cluster unlike the previous
one your IDs need to be unique across
the entire cluster and the silos they
are cluster aware
um
there's advantages and disadvantages to
that
the disadvantage is you have no control
or very little control which
um Silo a grain goes into
but because they are virtual actors and
you can use this grain Factory
everywhere even inside other grains and
you don't need to know where the cluster
has spun up a certain
um grain you can use a grain Factory to
get a reference to the actor that might
already be living somewhere
and that makes Discovery and addressing
a lot easier right in aka.net what
you'll probably be doing is passing the
actor reference around your network
because that is able to talk to the
actual actor instance whereas here you
can use the virtual addressing to make
that life a little bit easier right
but both of them are still quite similar
on the low level and they both Implement
some kind of ring communication to do
cluster Discovery and to detect which
nodes are going down and all of that
on the low end like they they function
really similar similarly to one another
so
what structure do you like best
do you prefer your actors to be in a
tree and where you have full control
over everything over the sharding but
you have to do everything yourself or do
you prefer the
um
easier flatter structure and where your
actors need to be uniquely id'd across
your entire okay interesting we have a
switch around here okay two points for
Lanes
and one for I could on that
right there's not a lot more than 40
people in this room so
let's move on now this is arguably
um
if you look at the differences between
these two Frameworks the way that
exceptions are handled
is probably what ties a lot of the
differences together
you'll see in a minute what I mean
now in Orleans
what happens if an exception is thrown
inside a grain
and
as I said like the input and output
parameters of those methods
they are wrapped in messages for us
and Orleans behind the scenes adds a
capability to send an exception back to
the caller right so if an exception is
thrown in the grain that exception gets
serialized it's it gets sent in the
response message to the calling threads
it gets deserialized there and it gets
rethrown right
so when you have an exception happening
in your grain and you're having this
task-based method that goes across the
network you will actually get that
um you will get that reception exception
thrown in your calling Tourette
the source is going to be different and
the call stack is going to be different
but like it will it will preserve
messages and and exception types and
stuff like that
right
um
there's a big advantage to that it's
like a very natural way of doing things
if you have been a c-sharp developer for
a long time there is also a big downside
um for this mechanism to function
properly you always have to wait for the
processing on the grain end to end right
because that's when your method will
return and then you know that no
exceptions happened
um
which means that if you're doing a long
processing talk also your calling thread
will pause for a very long time
so we can just call that handle grain
handle complete round on our grain
and we can catch the exception that is
coming from the Grain in the calling
threat right
very easy to reason about all you have
to remember is it does get serialized
and deserialized so your call stack is
going to be different
now in akka.net we use a concept called
supervision
um
and supervision any people here with
children
yeah okay if your children is behave in
a supermarket who is responsible
yeah right I have three kids and they
have my energy so I'm responsible a lot
um
now what happens is
errors in academic get escalated to the
parent
because we have this asynchronous tell
right we're dumping the message in the
inbox of the actor and our calling
thread is moving on it's not waiting for
the actor to finish the processing we
cannot escalate exceptions back to the
caller not in the way that we usually do
right
so the method that is being used inside
academic is called supervision and it
escalates it to its parent actor and the
parent will take a decision
it can either decide itself or further
escalate of the tree that is a
technicality it can basically do a
couple of things
it can say resume it's like your
exception your exception wasn't so bad
um
you can just drop this message and take
the next one from your inbox that's
basically what resume does
stop means it's like okay throw away
your inbox and kill off your actor
instance this exception is bad it's like
you need to stop don't do that to your
kids
um
but this is this is killing off the
actor instance and it throws away the
inbox with it
if you restart you preserve the inbox
but you do recycle the actor instance
and you will dispatch the same message
again to the new instance right so
that's the actions you can take you can
either reply it to only the failing
child or all of your children
um which makes sense if you have cut a
huge workload into multiple small pieces
and the whole thing is invalidated by
one exception right
now on the parent actor you will need to
do something like this you need to
override the supervisor strategy method
and you need to return a strategy that
inspects the exception and makes a
decision
so you get the exception from your child
and your parent can decide what this
child actor needs to do right if you get
a fatal exception
um
so one for one is only applying it to
the failing child if you get a fatal
exception you might want to stop if it
transients you might want may want to
restart and otherwise I otherwise we're
escalating right
so what do you prefer best for error
handling are we going to send it back to
the calling threat
or and retro and catch it there
or are we going to use a resiliency
mechanism with supervision and Community
you can communicate back to the sender
with a message if you would like
but then you have to do that in the
parent and it's not going to escalate
automatically
okay we're on two two
and we have 18 minutes left great
I think I'm on schedule
um
this ties it all together like this
supervision this is what made Erickson
so successful with those Telco systems
because you can build self-healing
systems anything that fails you can
handle inside the actor system build
your exponential backups if you want and
so on
now clients and
this is we are starting with akanau Okay
um
you're gonna have a cluster where your
sharded actors that are doing the actual
work are living right at some point
you're gonna want to talk to those
actors from the outside
probably sooner than later right
um
so in aka.net to be able to talk to an
actor from the outside if you have the I
actor ref that works really well
but the only way to get an ixrf from
outside an actor system is to actually
create it
[Music]
um
to create an actor in the actor system
as a top level actor and get a response
from that right and then you have an IAC
to ref you cannot do that for a node
that lives across the network
so the way that you usually talk to
actors that live in your cluster is to
spin up a client actor system
if you spin up a client actor system and
join it
to no don't do that okay and join it to
your cluster
and it can talk to all of the other
actors in the cluster and you can hold
the reference to your proxy actor that
is living in your client Vector system
so if you're talking to a bigger cluster
from an asp.net application what you're
going to do is spin up a small extra
system in that process that is going to
be talking to all of your other actors
right
um
and because of location transparency in
the iactor refs it means you can pass
around the iactor refs that you want and
then communicate to the actors directly
and if it need be
now Orleans is a lot more the way that
you're used to
if you spin up there's an actual Orleans
client library that allows you to talk
to a cluster and that client Library
gives you an injectable grain Factory
without actually spin spinning up an
entire actor system
and that allows you to make proxies for
actors that get instantiated over
um the cluster and also your client
library is cluster aware so when it
talks to the cluster if you do an actor
off and no it's not an actor off in
Orleans if you do a get grain and it is
not already living it will spin it up on
the right node according to the sharding
mechanism that it's using and those
proxies they work the same way that I
already showed you so in the startup
code of your application you're going to
use a host Builder
just the same way that you're used to in
in like asp.net applications you're
going to use the host Builder to build
the client and if you have that host you
can start it and it will contact the
cluster see which nodes there are and
you can start using it
and then that grains Factory
um
that is something
the cluster client is actually allowing
you to do get green and that will spin
up a grain somewhere around the cluster
if it's already there it will give you a
proxy that is able to talk to it right
so they have more of a vision around
like what clients should look like and
that is more in line with the rest of
um.net as a language right
so
I think I told talked about all of that
yeah this service you can inject into
your
um the eye controller and use that
so
what did you like best
and client actor system that needs to
join the cluster where you can spin up
your proxy actors and talk to the other
nodes in the cluster or a full-fledged
client library that is able to work in
the same way that a lot of other clients
are
okay Orleans is one ahead it's tree two
and then persistence I've been talking
about actors for 45 minutes now and I
haven't mentioned how
data gets there I mean we can spin up an
actor and send it messages on mute date
state but at some point like the actor
or the process is going to spin down and
it might come up after we restart it
and the data is going to be lost because
it's all Fields inside an object it's
going to be gone was in memory so at
some points we're going to want to write
that to a database
right
now the
way that Orleans does that is by using a
state object
and you can design your own it just
needs to be serializable that's it
and you can design your own and put any
number of fields or content into it all
the relevant state of your of your grain
should be in there you can have multiple
gray um State objects per crane if you
would so please what you need to do is
add them with the persist State
attribute to your Constructor of your
crane
and that will tell Orleans to inject the
correct State Management object for this
grain into the grain
and it's an i persistent State and the
way that we can write it to an
underlying storage technology is by
calling the state rights the the rights
data sync
and this persists the entire object
right the way that that works is it
persists the entire thing so next time
this actor with the same ID remember we
were using
um something with a good key or with an
integer key it's going to use that key
to re-query the state store to rehydrate
this actor when it spins up again so
that your state object is populated when
the actor comes back on and especially
in your Orleans Orleans takes a lot of
decisions about spinning down actors and
and bringing them back up up so if that
happens it's fully transparent it'll be
as if it was alive the whole time
right
that is the way that that works in or
lanes and you can use a number of
different persistence mechanisms
um you can use Azure blob store or table
story or a relational database or
document database like there's a whole
bunch of plugins that you can use with
that very similar to echo.net it also
supports a bunch of different storage
Technologies
it works a little bit differently we
start by inheriting from one of the
persistent actor bass classes which come
in the
um persistence package
and
the way that it works is is more of an
event sourced persistence model we now
get um it needs a persistence ID as I
said academic actors don't need a key
but when we need to rehydrate actors
when they have been down and they come
back up we need an ID to query the data
store and in echo.net you do that by
implementing the persistence ID property
um that needs to be unique across your
cluster
very important
and now we don't have a receive register
any registry anymore we have command and
recover
command is what is coming from the Inbox
and recover is what's coming from the
persistence mechanism when the actors
restart
so when we are getting recover messages
we don't want to re-persist them because
that will be a loop but if you call the
persist method
with the message that is what is going
to going to get written to your data
store and the handle method is going to
call the calls and that is going to
mutate your state in your actor right
and when this comes back up
um it will actually first see if there's
a snapshot and recover the snapshot then
it will get all the messages that were
that have happened since the snapshot
will bring all of those up we'll replay
those and then it will start accepting
messages from the inbox
um so all of that Maps really well if
you're doing any kind of event sourced
stuff
because this is event sourced by Nature
right
um so these are two different approaches
but basically what they both do is make
sure that we can recover State when
actors come back up after they have been
done right
so
which persistence model do you like
oh we have event sourcing fans here
it Maps really well if you build like a
ddds type system or a secure style
system with actors this persistence
model is going to help you tremendously
um we're at three three
so it might all come down to this one
um configuration
when we bring our processes
um we need to tell them how to
communicate to other nodes in the
cluster and how all of that is going to
work and and what we see in accra.net
this has come over from the jvm
implementation of of akka it's called
Hokum human optimized configuration
object notation
um yeah it's a mouthful
um it looks like Jason but it's not it's
not chasing compatible
um you can have this in files it parses
to a structure and you can apply
configurations on top of other
configurations to come to like a final
one
um it's very flexible but there's almost
no syntax highlighting for it so it's
not the most fun to work with but this
is the way you configure actor systems
you configure your persistence in here
you can configure your clustering and
your networking stay awake stay awake
um
and you can do all of that and at the
bottom you can see where the seed nodes
are that are the nodes that it already
knows about when it's joining a cluster
stuff like that right
now in our lanes we have to input the
same kind of information but in a
different way and again here you see the
host Builder again when we spin up a
silo that needs to join a cluster and it
needs to have persistence and whatever
it works with this host Builder with
um
all the methods that we can call on that
to add storage at persistence for timers
all that sort of stuff right
um
it's different but
which did you like
yeah I figured that that would go that
way
um that's okay Orleans is ahead
we have one last thing that I want to
show you before we wrap things up
and that is about performance
um
I did a little bit of benchmarking I did
bench end bench on my laptop
um
the amount of messages that I could
dispatch to actors on academ was 10
million a second
in Orleans it was 5 000 seconds
now you might think that that is a huge
difference
and and big reason that in my benchmarks
this was different is because I
could.net was not serializing and
deserializing the messages and Orleans
was
and I left I could have worked around
that but it's something that I wanna
put in here and so that you realize it's
like
um this is one of the big performance
differences between the two in Orleans
your messages will get serialized and
deserialized a lot quicker when you talk
to other actors whereas in accra.net if
you pass it around between actors on the
same node
um you're actually passing around the
object reference which is super fast
right and that attributes for a lot of
this
and if I would have like made it more
fair and enforced serialization and
deserialization in the aqua.net one I
think it would still have been faster
but not by this much right
also memory usage
um if I created a million actors on my
laptop and that took 900 megabytes which
means that the overhead for a single
actor in a release build is about 900
bytes so having a couple of million on a
single node is not going to hurt you
that much and it took 11 seconds to do
in Orleans it took twice as long and it
took twice the memory
now that may seem bad
um but what you get back in Orleans is a
lot of sensible defaults that have been
decided for you right but you're
sacrificing some performance for it and
if you want to have like the last bit of
performance out of your actors and your
actor systems you're gonna have more
knobs to turn and more things you can do
in academates
so I'm not going to let you vote I'm
going to give this point to akka
I have a problem now
um
because my conclusion was going to be
today's winner but this is a tie
so I'm gonna skip I had two slides for
for both of them so I'm gonna just skip
them
and um
no I'm not going to skip it I'm first
gonna
I'm gonna I want your opinion
um
I've always been opinionated on akka
because it's the one that I'm most
familiar with
um I wanted to take that out of today's
talk which is why I let you vote
I want your opinion like have I been
Fair towards or Lanes or not
um did you feel my preference throughout
this talk
um
okay that's good
that's great because that's what I
wanted to achieve that's why I did the
Voting and because I am opinionated
but I didn't want my opinion to be your
opinion I want to show how these things
are different different because I think
they're both really great
and
if if you ask me for my take and which
is why I'm giving it completely at the
end
and with academic you have full control
over a lot of things over your sharding
your messages your actual life cycles
yeah like you can turn all the knobs
which means you can squeeze every last
bit of performance from this if you want
but a lot of the stuff because of that
is way more explicit than the code
you will see the full message contracts
you will have to deal with sending
messages back to a sender and all of
that because all of it is built for
performance
but you will get that performance if you
go through the learning curve and
which is where Orleans comes in it's a
very opinionated implementation of the
actor model and you have to take my
opinion with a grain of salt but I think
that this works really well in a lot of
cases
and the performance numbers that I just
showed you it looks really drastic in a
real life scenario
I don't think it will matter that much
so if you want to get up to speed really
quickly with doing a distributed
distributed system that you can easily
scale out even or Lanes is Gonna Get You
ways further than API calls between
microservices will get you
and the abstractions that are leads made
are very sensible in a lot of scenarios
I felt very little friction when I was
working with it was easy to understand
it was very easy to get up to speed with
and it's a lot closer to the C sharp
that you might be used to when you're
doing asp.net applications for instance
um so don't steer away from Orleans
because of the performance numbers or
because of my personal preference I
think it's a great framework as well
um I think both of these have a place
to me it feels like Microsoft is going
to invest in Orleans a lot in the coming
years they're they've been giving it
um the time of day again they have been
quiet about it for five or six years
after they released it in 2015 but now
with Net 7 they're actually promoted
promoting it as a distributed
programming model in.net application so
we're going to see a lot of it and I
think that's exciting because I think we
should do more actor-based development
whenever we have
stateful High scale stuff that we need
to do like stateful concurrent stuff
this is a programming model that is
going to help you a lot
it doesn't matter which one of the two
you use they will work fine in a lot of
situations
I'm Hannis I'm the head of Learning and
Development and access in Belgium some
of my colleagues are here in the front
row that's my Twitter handle and my seq
number I've been trying for four years
to make icq great again
um over four years three people have
messaged me on the icq app yes they have
an app yes it is being maintained yes it
still works and you can activate your
old icq numbers
and that was my story
right on time
I'm not sure if we're allowed to take
some questions before we get coffee
I'll tell you this if you want to walk
out and grab coffee like walk out
otherwise come up and ask the questions
over here while I pack up my laptop
thank you